for you individually though
does it make you sad that your brain
ends that you die
one day very soon that the whole thing
that that uh that data source just goes
offline
sooner than you would like that's a
complicated question i
i would have answered it differently in
different times of my life i
you know i had chronic depression for 10
years and so in that 10-year time period
i desperately wanted lights to be off
and the thing that made it even worse is
i was in a religious
i was born into a religion it was the
only reality i ever understood and
it's difficult to articulate to people
when you're born into that kind of
reality and it's the only reality you're
exposed to
you are literally blinded to the
existence of other realities because
it's so much
the in-group out group thing and so in
that
situation it was not only that i
desperately wanted lights out
forever it was that i couldn't have
lights out forever it was there was an
afterlife
and this afterlife had this
system that would either penalize or or
reward you for your behaviors and so
it's almost like this
is indescribable hopelessness
of not only being in hopeless despair
of not wanting to exist but then also
being forced to be to exist
and so there was a duration of my time
of deterioration of life where i'd say
yes i have no remorse
for lights being out and actually want
it more than anything in the entire
world
there are other times where i'm looking
out at the future and i say
this is an opportunity for a future
evolving human conscious experience that
is beyond
my ability to understand and and i jump
out of bed and i race to work and i
i can't think about anything else but i
i think the the reality for me is
i don't know what it's like to be in
your head but in my head when i wake up
in the morning
i don't say good morning brian i'm so
happy to see you like i'm sure
you're just going to be beautiful to me
today you're not going to make a huge
long list of everything you should be
anxious about
you're not going to repeat that list to
me 400 times you're not going to have me
relive all the regrets i've made in life
i'm sure you're not doing any of that
you're just going to just
help me along all day long it's a brutal
environment in my brain
and we've just become normalized to this
environment that we just accept that
this is what it means to be human
but if we look at it if we try to muster
as much soberness as we can
about the realities of being human it's
brutal
if it is for me and so
am i sad that the brain may be off one
day
you know it depends on the contextual
setting like how am i feeling what
moment are you asking me that and that's
it's my mind is so fickle
and this is why again i don't trust my
conscious mind i have been
given realities i was given a religious
reality
that was a video game and then i figured
out it was not
a real reality and then i lived in a
depressive reality which delivered
this terrible hopelessness that wasn't a
real reality then i discovered
behavioral psychology and i figured out
how biased 188 chronicle biases and how
my brain is distorting reality all the
time
i have gone from one reality to another
i don't trust
reality i don't trust realities are
given to me
and so to make try to make a decision on
what i value or not value that future
state
i don't trust my response so not fully
not fully listening to the conscious
mind at any one moment
as the ultimate truth but allowing it to
go up and down
as it does and just kind of being
observing it yes i assume
that whatever my conscious mind delivers
up to my awareness
is wrong on pawn landing
and i just need to figure out where it's
wrong how it's wrong how wrong it is
and then try to correct for it as best i
can but i
i assume that on impact it's mistaken
in some critical ways is there something
you can say
by way of advice when the mind is
depressive when the conscious mind
serves up something that
uh you know the dark thoughts
how you deal with that like how in your
own life you've overcome that and others
who are experiencing that
can overcome it two things one
that those depressive
states are biochemical states
it's not you
and the suggestions that these things
that this state delivers to you about
suggestion of the hopelessness of lice
or
or the meaninglessness of it or
that you should hit the eject button
that's a false reality
yeah and that it's when
i i completely understand the
rational decision to commit suicide
there's it is not lost to me at all that
that is a and that is an irrational
situation but the key is when you're in
that situation those thoughts are
landing
to be able to say thank you you're not
real
i know you're not real yeah and so i'm
in a situation where for whatever reason
i'm having this
this uh neurochemical state but
that state can be altered and so it
again it goes back to the realities of
the difficulties of being human
and like when i was trying to solve my
depression i tried literally
ev you name it i tried it systematically
and
nothing would fix it and so this is what
gives me hope with
brain interfaces for example like could
i have numbers on my brain
can i see what's going on because i go
to the doctor and it's like how do you
feel i don't know
terrible like on a scale from under 10
to how bad you want to commit suicide
10. okay at this moment
here's here's his bottle how much i take
well i don't know like just
yeah it's very very crude and as data
opens up the
the yeah it opens up the possibility of
really helping
in those dark moments to first
understand
the the waves the ups and downs and
those dark models on the complete flip
side of that i
i am uh very conscious in my own brain
and deeply deeply grateful that
what they're it's it's almost like a
chemistry thing a biochemistry thing
that i go many times throughout the day
i'll
i'll look at like this cup
and i'll be overcome with joy how
amazing it is to be alive
like i actually think i'm my
biochemistry is such that it's not
as common like i've talked to people
and i don't think that's that common
like it's a
and it's not a rational thing at all
it's like
i feel like i'm on drugs and i'll just
be like
whoa and a lot of people talk about like
the meditative experience will
allow you to sort of you know look at
some basic things like the movement of
your hand
as uh deeply joyful because it's like
that's life
but i get that from just looking at a
cup like i'm waiting for the coffee to
brew and i'll just be like
[ __ ] life is awesome and i'll sometimes
tweet that but then i'll like regret it
later like god damn it you're so
uh ridiculous but yeah so but that
is purely chemistry like
there's no rational it doesn't fit with
the rest of my life i have all this [ __ ]
i'm always late to stuff i'm always like
there's all stuff
you know i'm super self-critical like
really self-critical about everything i
do
i only to the point i almost hate
everything i do but there's this engine
of joy
for life outside of all that and that
has to be chemistry and the flip side of
that
is what depression probably is is the
opposite of that feeling
of like because i i bet you that feeling
of
the cup being amazing is would save
anybody in a state of depression like
that that would be like fresh
you're in a desert and it's a drink of
water
[ __ ] man the brain is a it would be nice
to understand where that's coming from
to be able to um to understand the
how you hit those lows and those highs
that have nothing to do with the actual
reality
it has to do with some very specific
aspects
of how you maybe see the world maybe it
could be just like basic habits that you
engage in and then
how to walk along the line to to find
those experiences of joy
and this goes back to the discussion
we're having of human cognition
is in volume the largest input
of raw material into society yeah and
it's not quantified we have no bearings
on it
and so we just you wonder
we both articulated some of the
challenges we have in our own mind
and it's likely that others would say
i have something similar yeah and you
wonder when you look at society
what how does that contribute to all the
other
compounder problems that we're
experiencing how does that
blind us to the uh the opportunities we
could be looking at
and so it really it has this potential
distortion effect on reality that just
makes everything worse
and i hope if we can put some
if we can assign some numbers to these
things just to get our bearings
so we're aware of what's going on if we
could find greater stabilization in how
we conduct our lives and how we build
society
it might be the thing that enables us to
scaffold
uh because we've really again we've done
it a human has done a fantastic job
systematically scaffolding
technology and science institutions it's
humans it's our
own selves which we have not been able
to scaffold it's it's we are the we are
the one
part of this intelligence infrastructure
that remains unchanged
you